there's a few things about three things
to my account that I need I want to miss
something to look up to another is
something to look forward to and another
is someone to Chase
first off I want to thank God because
that's who I look up to
my family
that's who and what I look forward to to
my father who I know is up there right
now to my mother who's here tonight to
my wife Camilla and my kids you are the
four people in my life that I want to
make
the most proud of me and to my hero
that's who I chase it's me in 10 years
so you see every day every week every
month and every year of my life my
Hero's always 10 years away I'm never
going to be my hero and that's just fine
with me because that keeps me with
somebody to keep on chasing
so to any of us whatever it is we look
up to
whatever it is we look forward to and
whoever it is we're chasing to that I
say Amen to that I say all right all
right all right
all right